à ce soir bridget a put un mail vous
vous demandez parfois quoi penser aux
animaux or elle me manque tellement
j'ai oublié mon portable elle me manque
tellement de quoi il parle
ravi de vous rencontrer aujourd'hui et
ce qu'ils font quand vous n'êtes pas là
tu sais quoi lundi j'ai un plan tout est
détaillé les actions lui manque un
boulon à la peluche la maxe j'étais très
excité yuke et il va être ton ton frère
chloé j'ai un gros problème je suis ton
avis et en tant qu'ami je vais être
franche avec toi je me fiche pas mal de
tes problèmes assez mon appart
maintenant et mon petit que tu a piqué
une crise que tu vas voir ça cathy elle
va flipper graf
mais c'est qu'un vase un vase duke au
vase oh mais c'est terrible il va pas
rester longtemps et max
adieu alors on se promène du ray qui
t'as fait ça n'ont pas disparu moi je
regarde partout regarde moi dont je vais
me sortir de taule
ok les gars vous avez rien de là ça
marche je vais retrouver votre ami alors
comment tu te sens grand-père par ali g
tu conduis comme un cochon
je suis un héros tromper mais s'il est
trop stylé
comme des dettes soit bien sage renard
vous demandez parfois quoi penser aux
animaux elle me manque tellement
j'ai oublié mon portable trop elle me
manque tellement de quoi il parle
ravi de vous rencontrer aujourd'hui et
ce qu'il fout quand vous n'êtes pas là
j'en ai chargés oui j'ai plein de
projets j'ai un plan tout est détaillé
lui manque un boulon à la plus
comme des bêtes